هناك مشكلة أخرى متشابكة مع هواوي
تُظهر مدى قوة
شركة الاتصالات الصينية هذه من ناحية ، حيث مارست
الولايات المتحدة ضغوطًا لا تصدق
على المملكة المتحدة ودول
أخرى لإخراج Huawei من أنظمة G الخمسة الخاصة
بها ، لكن العديد من
الشركات البريطانية لديها بالفعل  دفعت مقابل
هذه المعدات ،
ولهذا السبب تعتبر هذه المشكلة حساسة للغاية مع
تيريزا ماي وحكومتها الآن على
الرغم من وجود الكثير من
العناوين السلبية حول أرقام Huawei الجديدة
التي تظهر مدى قوة الشركة
مع المستهلكين ومدى شعبيتها.
المستهلكون على الرغم من أن
سوق الهواتف الذكية في حالة تراجع
حول العالم ، فإن سامسونج التي تراها في هذه
الأرقام تفقد حجمها ، فقد انخفض
بنسبة 8 في المائة على أساس سنوي ، بينما تأتي آبل
الآن في المركز الثالث ، حيث انخفضت بنسبة 30 في المائة ولكن
انظر إلى هؤلاء  ارتفعت الأرقام المذهلة من
Huawei بنسبة 50٪ ، أحد الأسباب هو
أنهم حققوا أداءً جيدًا في الصين مع
الحرب التجارية
، حيث توقف الصينيون عن شراء العديد من
منتجات Apple وهم  بدأوا في شراء
المزيد من منتجات Huawei ، لكنه يُظهر أيضًا
ابتكاراتهم المذهلة لأن
هناك الكثير من العناوين السلبية
التي نسي الكثيرون أن Huawei قد
تقدمت بشكل نهائي على Apple عندما
يتعلق الأمر بابتكار الهواتف الذكية
، سيكون لديهم هاتف ذكي 5G قبل
Apple بالطبع وبالطبع  سيكون لديهم
هاتف قابل للطي قبل Apple ، لذا
فهي الصين الكلاسيكية ، بمعنى أن
Huawei
تنظر إلى الصورة الكبيرة وتقول
دائمًا إنها ستلتقي حول الأشخاص الذين سيستخدمون
منتجاتنا التي قد لا تكون صحيحة في
الولايات المتحدة في الوقت الحالي ولكن  في بقية
أنحاء العالم ، تتقدم Huawei في Samuel
Burke CNN London